[Música]
los altos funcionarios de la casa blanca
viajarán aquí para reunirse con el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
según lo anunció el mandatario selenski
reiteró que si las tropas rusas matan a
militares que resisten en mariupol no
habrá más negociaciones
rusia aumenta sus ataques en el dow más
el gobernador de lugar afirmó que al
menos seis civiles murieron en un
bombardeo en las últimas obras esto
ocurre un día después de que rusia
afirmara que quería controlar esta
región y el sur de ucrania
israel cerrará el cruce con la franja de
gaza en respuesta al lanzamiento de
varios cohetes hacia el suelo israelí
los enfrentamientos se enmarcan en la
ola de violencia en pleno ramadán en la
que han muerto al menos 29 palestinos y
14 israelíes
[Música]
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y empezamos con
lo más reciente de la guerra en ucrania
el presidente de ese país por lo vivir
se les dio una rueda de prensa en la que
anunció que el secretario de estado de
eeuu anthony blinken y el secretario de
defensa joy austin irán aquí es mañana
domingo según el mandatario hablarán de
las armas que necesitan los ucranianos y
del ritmo de entrega aunque la casa
blanca no hizo ningún pronunciamiento la
visita es la primera que hace el
gobierno estadounidense luego de ser
criticado por no ir a ucrania a
diferencia de lo que han hecho varios
líderes europeos se le es que espera que
el presidente de eeuu joe biden vaya
pronto y criticó que el secretario de la
onu antonio guterres viaje primero a
moscú que aquí es escuchemos lo que dijo
sobre el viaje de los estadounidenses
no creo que sea un gran secreto aunque
no sé si es público todavía mañana llega
agente de eeuu tendrá una reunión con el
ministro de defensa y el secretario de
estado el señor blinken amblin quien am
de ese modo estamos esperando por
circunstancias de seguridad para
permitir que el presidente de eeuu
llegue y apoye a la nación ucraniana
mitre mate ukrainski además el
presidente volodymyr selenski reiteró
que dejarán de negociar con rusia y las
tropas enviadas por moscú matan a los
soldados que todavía resisten el
mariupol hoy los militares rusos
bombardearon de nuevo la fábrica de
acero de as hostal en esa ciudad donde
estaba atrincherado el último foco de
resistencia ucraniana se les he también
advirtió que rechazan un referendo en la
ciudad de gerzón que ya controlan los
rusos
si nuestros hombres son asesinados en
mariupol y si estos pseudo referéndums
se organizan en nuevas pseudo repúblicas
entonces ucrania se retirará de
cualquier proceso de negociación ukraine
with this week y por el mundo proxes
mientras tanto los ataques han aumentado
en la región del donbass en el este
ucraniano donde se concentra la nueva
fase de la operación militar de los
rusos
de lugansk denunció que al menos seis
civiles murieron en bombardeos recientes
mientras que el estado mayor de las
fuerzas armadas de ucrania afirma que
repelieron ocho ataques rusos en lugar y
en donges que en las últimas 24 horas
por su parte de la organización para la
seguridad y la cooperación en europa
denunció que varios de los miembros de
su misión nacional fueron retenidos en
esas dos provincias lado se precisó que
están intentando establecer canales de
comunicación para poder liberarlos
y en el sur de ucrania al menos cinco
personas murieron y 18 resultaron
heridas en un ataque con misiles en la
ciudad portuaria de odessa para el
comando aéreo del sur de ucrania aseguró
que los misiles impactaron en una
instalación militar y en dos edificios
residenciales sin embargo los rusos
dicen que el objetivo del ataque fue un
depósito donde se guardaban armas
enviadas por eeuu y la unión europea
este ataque ocurre luego de que el
comandante adjunto del distrito militar
central de rusia afirmara que moscú
quiere controlar el sur de ucrania para
poder llegar hasta el territorio de
transnistria en moldavia desde dmitro
una de nuestras enviadas especiales
leticia álvarez nos reportó cuál es la
importancia de lo que ocurre en odessa
el ejército ruso ha atacado la ciudad
portuaria de odessa dos misiles han
impactado contra un edificio de
viviendas y un edificio militar hay
cinco fallecidos o de esa es una ciudad
clave para este país apenas había sido
atacada tiene más de 800 mil habitantes
y es muy significativo este lanzamiento
de misiles porque se produce horas
después de que un alto cargo militar
ruso avisara de que odessa está bajo el
punto de mira porque quieren controlar
todo ese flanco sur el ministro de
exteriores culé va denunciado que estos
ataques forman parte de una campaña para
aterrorizar a todos los ciudadanos de
este país de forma simultánea también ha
sido atacado la ciudad de kharkiv que es
frente de batalla y a quién ni pero
dónde nos encontramos las defensas
antiaéreas se han derribado un misil
justo en el parque que tenemos a
nuestras espaldas donde han caído los
fragmentos a esa hora el parque estaba
abierto en el norte de ucrania
aprovechar el retiro de las tropas rusas
para intentar reconstruir las urbes por
odian acá ubicada a 60 kilómetros de la
capital es una de las ciudades más
destruidas por la guerra con el 40 por
ciento de su infraestructura dañada les
contamos la historia en el siguiente
informe un ejemplo entre muchos otros de
la magnitud de la destrucción en boro
janka y de la enorme tarea de
reconstrucción que se avecina antes de
la guerra estos dos edificios eran uno
solo pero un bombardeo ruso a principios
de marzo destruyó la parte central ya no
queda nada 40 por ciento de las
estructuras están afectadas la
reconstrucción parece imposible pero los
habitantes están convencidos de que si
es posible en este barrio estos
trabajadores se encargan del primer paso
la demolición de las casas que están
demasiado dañadas como aquí estamos
quitando las tuberías de gas para que
los demás servicios puedan intervenir
arrasar los edificios y reconstruir
otros nuevos una vez terminada la
búsqueda de las víctimas la vida como
era antes tardará meses probablemente
años en volver pero este residente está
dispuesto a esperar
volver un día no rendirse al enemigo a
pesar del trauma aunque nueve de sus
vecinos han desaparecido
vamos a quedarnos aquí hay que
reconstruir por odian acá tenemos que
ponernos a trabajar soy un antiguo
soldado no quiero irme
cuando todavía es posible como en estas
viviendas sociales los habitantes se
apresuran a reparar
será posible volver aquí tan pronto como
se restablezca el gas y la electricidad
tras la limpieza esta mujer procede al
inventario de lo que los ocupantes le
han robado
reconstruir es también volver a comprar
las ventanas se habían caído y las
reparamos pero nos robaron las joyas la
ropa la comida también creo que tenían
hambre incluso nos robaron la basura el
futuro devoró dianca dependerá de los
medios financieros que se le concedan
quién pagará por ejemplo las obras de
las numerosas casas destruidas los
habitantes a menudo no tienen el dinero
necesario y el estado ve como su
economía se hunde por la guerra por el
momento el 90 por ciento del flujo de
efectivo de la ciudad proviene de la
ayuda humanitaria en otras noticias
israel cerrará su cruce fronterizo con
la franja de gaza lo que impide el paso
de 12.000 trabajadores palestinos que
tienen permisos el organismo militar de
israel que controla los asuntos civiles
en gaza anunció que la reapertura
dependerá de una evaluación de seguridad
el cruce se cerró luego de que
militantes palestinos dispararan tres
misiles entre el viernes y el sábado la
más reciente detención comenzó hace un
mes con una serie de ataques en
territorio israelí y luego con las
redadas del ejército en cisjordania al
menos 14 israelíes y 29 palestinos han
muerto
ciertamente el cierre del cruce de beit
hanún frente a 12.000 palestinos en este
momento cuando nos acercamos al ayat
fito tendrá repercusiones en 12.000
familias y en la economía palestina
dentro de la franja de gaza donde 3
millones de shekels ingresan a la franja
todos los días
y en kuala lumpur malasia protestaron
este sábado en contra de la ejecución en
los próximos días de un hombre que sufre
de discapacidad cognitiva según los
abogados de la defensa a finales de
marzo el tribunal aseguró que no hay
evidencia que demuestre la condición
mental de esta persona mientras que
desestimó una solicitud para que fuera
evaluado por un panel independiente de
psiquiatras la única esperanza es un
indulto presidencial de si camps u de
singapur melissa chávez tiene la
historia
ciudadanos protestan frente a la
embajada de singapur y malasia exigen la
liberación de un hombre con discapacidad
cognitiva condenado a morir ahorcado el
próximo miércoles por intentar traficar
menos de 43 gramos de heroína a singapur
y hoy estamos todos aquí con un motivo
que es salvar anaga entrar y detener
esta ejecución estamos orando todos
juntos con él esperamos que se salve que
esté bien y de vuelta a malasia yo quise
ser un psicólogo de la defensa que
evaluarán haga entran asegura que es un
coeficiente intelectual es de 69 una
medición que la organización mundial de
la salud reconoce como una
característica de discapacidad
intelectual sin embargo el tribunal de
singapur aseguró que el joven sabía lo
que hacía al violar las rígidas leyes
antidrogas del país y desestimó una
solicitud para que fuera evaluado por un
panel independiente de psiquiatras al
rechazo por la sentencia se han sumado
organizaciones de derechos humanos como
abogados por la libertad será enviado a
la horca el 27 de abril por lo que
estamos aquí para mostrar nuestro
descontento con las acciones del
gobierno de singapur al seguir adelante
con esta ejecución a pesar de que es un
hombre con discapacidad intelectual a
pesar de que su salud mental se ha
deteriorado mientras todo este calvario
continúa todas las vías legales que
podían detener la ejecución se agotaron
el ahorcamiento del hombre de 34 años
fue programado en noviembre se encuentra
en el corredor de la muerte desde hace
unos 12 años su única esperanza es un
indulto proveniente de la presidencia de
singapur
se reportó un nuevo caso de evo la
república democrática del congo es el
primero desde que la oms declaró el fin
del último brote de la enfermedad en el
país el caso fue confirmado por el
instituto nacional de investigaciones
biológicas y se reportó en la ciudad
norteña de mbandaka la capital de la
provincia de qatar con esto resurge en
república democrática del congo un virus
que desde el 16 de diciembre de 2021 ya
se había controlado el último brote que
fue el decimotercero provocó 11 casos y
6 muertos en la provincia nororiental de
kivú del norte y entre 2018 y 2020 el
ébola mató a cerca de 2.300 personas en
ese país según la ong sin embargo las
autoridades hacen un llamado a la calma
en noticias latinoamericana a cientos de
personas en chile protestaron en contra
de la nueva carta magna que está
redactando la convención constitucional
los manifestantes de derechas se
congregaron en el centro de la capital
santiago como ha sido habitual en las
últimas semanas a mitad de la
concentración en un grupo de
encapuchados empezó a tirar piedras y
agredir a los manifestantes lo que
provocó la intervención del cuerpo
policial de carabineros en septiembre de
este año los chilenos votarán para
aprobar o rechazar la nueva constitución
luego de que en 2020 casi un 80 por
ciento de los votantes aprobaran cambiar
la carta magna que venía desde los
tiempos del dictador augusto pinochet
y francia elegirá a quien ocupará la
presidencia durante los próximos cinco
años mañana casi 49 millones de
franceses podrán acudir a las urnas en
la segunda vuelta electoral en vísperas
de estos comicios algunos municipios
carecen de asesores que son voluntarios
que velan por el buen funcionamiento de
los colegios electorales y son
esenciales para el proceso
en los colegios electorales las
papeletas y las urnas están listas pero
al igual que la primera vuelta faltan
asesores que ayuden a atender las mesas
necesitamos dos asesores por colegio
electoral tenemos 70 colegios
electorales en la ciudad y hay muchos en
los que sólo hay un asesor lo mismo
ocurre en bergerac en dordoña en los
últimos días hemos tenido cancelaciones
por casos de kobin común también es
cierto que el tiempo que se realiza la
segunda vuelta no es muy bueno en
términos de calendario tres zonas
estarán de vacaciones al mismo tiempo en
francia los asesores se eligen de tres
maneras entre los representantes de los
partidos políticos entre los votantes
locales o entre los funcionarios locales
como en el caso de frío donde el alcalde
y pidió a un administrador municipal que
ayudará en un colegio electoral
siempre es interesante poder participar
en este tipo de operaciones ver desde
dentro cómo se celebran unas elecciones
las normas del código electoral son
estrictas además de los dos asesores se
necesitan un presidente y un secretario
para gestionar las urnas la escasez de
voluntarios suele provocar una mayor
espera para los votantes
y a propósito de estas elecciones los
invitamos a que se conecten mañana a
domingo con el especial de la segunda
vuelta de las presidenciales en francia
a partir de las 12 del mediodía en
ciudad de méxico bogotá quito y lima
comenzaremos nuestra transmisión
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]